[Musique]
j'ai donné nous avons choisi la belle
époque adapté à l'enfant
oui parce que c'est une époque qui ne
s'adaptent pas par définition tellement
à l'enfant non seulement nous y avons
recherché en présentant des animaux et
personnages humoristiques la possibilité
d'appeler l'attention de l'enfant et de
la muse et en lui faisant connaître en
même temps une époque qui est déjà
révolu
vous avez quand même réussi à
reconstituer le moulin rouge en
l'adaptant l'enfance nous l'avons adapté
à l'enfance
voyez ce sont des pour l'enfant pour la
petite fille ce sont des poupées qui
tourne ça n'évoque pas absolument de
fans chantant mais pour l'adulte lui et
lui tombera son expression mais vous
avez aussi reconstitué d'autres choses
de la belle époque
nous avons constitué dans ce
sens un coin des buttes chaumont qui est
un coin pour les enfants
où ils le retrouvent le train de
ceinture d'autrefois avec une locomotive
qui lui inspire toujours l'enfant
toujours la locomotive le train pour
l'enfant c'est quelque chose de très
important
nous avons également retracé les
différents thèmes de l'époque sur le
boulevard de clichy en faisant la foule
de cette époque en essayant de
représenter les personnages tel qu'il
était mais en accentuant les défauts de
ses personnages ce qui provoque la
gaieté de l'enfant ils aiment trouver
chez les grandes personnes
les défauts que peut-être on lui
reproche à lui-même et ce qu'il trouve
très drôle ça plaît quand même aux
adultes
et ça plaît aux abonnés il y a
énormément d'adultes qui viennent voir
notre spectacle en général une très
grande proportion sans doute parce que
ça lui rappelle aussi leurs souvenirs
d'enfant
tél
[Musique]
ok
au débat difficile à thème tous les
jouets
qu'est ce qui fait au fond c'est plus le
mouvement qui plaît aux enfants
la couleur que le thème lui-même
l'enfant s'attache aux détails du
personnage chaque fois qu'ils trouvent
le défaut
est amusant n'était merveille et il est
amusé est ce que nous avons cherché
c'est justement cet amusement des
enfants c'est émerveillement c'est nous
les faire sortir de la vie courante pour
les faire entrer dans un thème différent
[Musique]